[Music]
my
i'm beryl i produce a series called
around the world where i take one topic
and look at its iterations around the
world
a couple of episodes back i did coffee
and the tea drinkers of the world came
for me
and i heard you
i do like tea
i dabble
but i also realize that after water tea
is the most popular beverage on the
planet
so
i spoke to seven people in seven
countries
to see the different ways that people
drink tea around the world
so this
is the tea episode
[Music]
in making this episode i decided two
things
one i'm not going to do instant tea so
i'm looking for how people prepare tea
and two the tea should be authentic to
the country that we are in so the
starbucks matcha latte down the street
here in new york city is not fair game
okay let's begin
here in england we are a tea drinking
nation english breakfast tea is an
tea is an important part of
everybody's life in india this tea is
specially called masala
[Music]
butter
[Music]
i'm normally a coffee drinker however in
the spirit of the video i'm gonna be
replacing my coffee for the week with
the teas that we're talking about in the
video
so
day one i have a traditional english
cuppa i need black tea milk and sugar
fun fact for this video i'm actually
using loose leaf black tea however in
england 96 of tea drinkers use tea bags
i have been told that when you add the
milk is pretty important
[Music]
just a splash
in cornwall as with the rest of the
country this is a matter of some debate
but here we will always add the milk
last
my name's ryan bray i'm the food and
beverage manager here at plurian on the
lizard
tea is definitely a very old practice
here in england so it became really
popular in the 17th century when it was
popularized by king charles ii
in terms of preparation you definitely
want boiling water it has to be at least
100 degrees for a black tea otherwise
you'll find it won't steep properly
after a brewing time of precisely three
minutes which is the most ideal time for
brewing a black tea
you have the option of milk or sugar
it can be a full sit-down affair like
our full afternoon tea
you will have cakes you'll have your tea
your sandwiches and famously your scones
i think that the tradition of drinking
tea in england is one that's really
ingrained in our way of life it really
is
probably the one thing that absolutely
everybody has in common
drink tea on every occasion man because
there is no occasion for tea tea is the
occasion
[Music]
today is day two and i'm going to be
making moroccan tea i need green gum
powder tea some mint i'm using dried
mint and sugar
do not forget the sugar
traditionally in morocco tea service is
done by the male head of the house and
it's a tradition that is passed down
from father to son kind of interesting
[Music]
yeah that's sweet but it's really good
[Music]
[Music]
one
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
today is day three and i'm going to be
drinking yerba mate which i have never
had ever uh mate is actually pretty
interesting because it has its own
vocabulary so you drink out of a cup
that is called a mate it is
traditionally a hollowed out gourd and
you drink with a straw that's called a
bombilla the bombilla has tiny holes at
the bottom that helps filter out the
yerba mate that is in your cup
okay i'm gonna try it
it's bitter definitely i would say a bit
of an acquired taste
i like drinking out of the straw that's
fun
i could get down with this today
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
argentina
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
today is day four and i'm drinking
russian style black tea what does that
mean it means i'm gonna be drinking
strong black tea fun fact about me i
actually used to live in russia so i
have intimate knowledge on how to make
this
this is the black tea concentrate you're
gonna add just a little bit on the
bottom
and then top it off with however much
water you want to dilute it
i don't know i guess i did half a cup i
do like a strong tea i'm not adding any
sugar to this one
oh it's hot
i burned my tongue but it's really good
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
today is day five and i am drinking
japanese matcha not in a latte just
plain hot water no sugar
it's pretty high in caffeine so a little
goes a long way at least for me to make
matcha you use a whisk you can use any
whisk really but there is a matcha whisk
and you want to put it in a bowl and do
zigzag motions until you see little
bubbles form and then you know the
matcha is ready
it's nice actually matcha has a really
earthy taste and i like it
[Music]
a
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it is day six and i'm making a tea that
is close to my home and my heart masala
chai from india
so the first time that i learned to make
masala chai was when i went to india to
get married my mother-in-law taught me i
didn't really speak any hindi she didn't
really speak any english but we didn't
need language to communicate i don't
know it was just this really beautiful
moment something i'll never forget
oh this smells so good
yum
a common mistake that americans make is
they say chai tea chai is actually the
word for tea so it's like saying tea tea
yeah the more you know
[Music]
yeah yum this is really good my
mother-in-law would definitely be proud
we begin our day with having a cup of
chai
you put the chai on your burner the
first thing in the morning the whole
house wakes up and you get the smell all
over the house
my name is sunita banerjee
i live in mumbai india
the spices which you grind together our
ginger cardamom cinnamon
and if you like even a few peppercorns
to add a little bit of
watercolor make it a little more spicy
just grind it all together and add it to
your boiling water
add your tea leaves according to your
taste if you like it strong a little
more otherwise just one teaspoon per cup
approximately
let the whole concoction start boiling
add milk
and your tea is done
my father would say that the perfect cup
of tea when you have a sip of it it
should give you a taste of a biscuit
i think
tea has a very very important role to
play in every indians life
[Music]
today is the last day and i'm going to
be drinking taiwanese bubble tea i will
be making my own boba which i have here
and i have black tea that i was steeping
so this is a concentrate so that you can
still taste the tea flavor once i add
all of the milk and sugar there
definitely aren't that many health
benefits to bubble tea but if we're
talking about emotional benefits it
makes you feel amazing
so there's that
i mean
it looks pretty good
yum
i don't have the right straw so
i'm gonna use a spoon
yum bubble tea just makes you feel good
you know
[Music]
i wanna know
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here is what i've taken away from this
project
tea clearly can be a lot of different
things it can look different it can
taste different however the through line
that i have seen is that tea is not
actually about the tea itself it's
always nice to have a cup of tea and
relax however
it's about people and it's about
hospitality it's about togetherness
tea is something that in general is best
enjoyed with others
tea is hard for every reason to
socialize to be with friends
any time it's try time it's like a
social cement you can't go anywhere
without someone immediately offering you
a cup of tea
it is
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
you